so clarence
yeah are you a hillbilly oh yeah i'm a
hillbilly i'm i'm from hell man
i'm supporting the hill right there i go
up on the hill get a busy goat
gotta go up into heaven like oh great
hit my littlest dog man
get a
foreign
man
it's a clearance okay clarence where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally well i'm from uh
leicester county kentucky right there
hiding kentucky right there you know
and uh uh you grew up with both your
parents uh i lived my grand my granddad
raised me from town called hospital top
six and my grandma passed down her
and i went somewhere daddy moments i was
about eight and my dad got divorced
and i went to uh i come up here on uh
bull skin the 1418 boys getting around
let's scare you
there and i stayed here i was 13 my
grandpa took me back home right there
and i stayed with him so i got a job
when i was about 19 at third
seven like working as a butcher and uh
what kind of jobs did you have
throughout your life
well i only worked though i worked at a
sailor for a few years as a butcher
still
i had a head busters in the box of meat
department
and then uh i worked a little faster
i've done jackson tucker there i am
stuck there as
i just got about seven right urine and i
forgot so security
did you ever work uh in a coal mine like
a lot of guys hey no i don't work in the
coal mine now
they they about going around here yeah
yeah
um you know when i was with bar turtle i
wouldn't be a guitar attorney
and they got one up about seven or eight
silver blue boys
and i've been playing music to write
songs ever since since i was about seven
or eight
was there was there a lot of musicians
in your in your head yeah yeah
but everybody remember i got a cousin
indiana right there mark roger
he got a southern rock man he plays for
my great grand my granddaughters are you
still a manual figure there's sam caster
and he uh
he he played a banjo and uh you know i
got respect and i got a cousin yeah he
played
he's like many people get anything here
you can get a song just pick it up
by here you know you know the monkeys is
my family
my favorite thing was fighting chicken
though yeah i've been fighting chicks i
was about ten there
so like [ __ ] fighting yeah cops on you
and no
is that what you do for a living now no
i don't do it for a living which i do
for phone or you got
i raised my cell phone right there
because you taking back i got some pure
young jefferson right there where does
the [ __ ] fighting rooster get you
well around you i mean four fingers
that's seven four thousand dollars a
piece right there how much forty
thousand you take like
uh thousand dollars that's something
that louisiana was legally a thousand
dollar each fair turn 1980
12
was taking the corridor i had my feet
and everything for fighting chickens and
they shut down i used to get a game cup
magazine
about two months ago they got they put
some magazine and everything right there
yeah they should dance 1976 against the
law fight chicken
in 1834 right there in england so they
shut it down because i think they shout
out a lot of your english
and now he says they should down here so
you so you raise and sell
you have raised some or something you
know if you guys can find that you seem
to like the philippines and sons at
logiana
and uh mace goes towards lego if i get
you in here they give
about 14 months is it 14 months for
fried chicken first finish
so tell me about the what is it about
roosters that they like to they like to
kill each other
oh that's just like a you know you know
boxing stuff like
it's like a boxer or have to be
like a howling shelter they can be only
one when they say roasted their heads
start saying they
hate it and that's what they do they
like like route they've seen it before
where they just
if they're exposed to each other they're
going to try to kill each other yeah
yeah that's basically that's what that's
the best thing
don't know they don't they have to be
boss or die did they after his partner
didn't be only one yeah
and uh
so you how much schooling did you get oh
i went about
i wasn't a five year plan so i like
three crazy great ones there so i went
to uh
got the james bass course on this horse
right there seven of walks with her and
was adult learning center
so you eventually got a high school
education gdp general education yeah
and i mostly studied i didn't go to
college and i must have studied anatomy
and breeding anything they were chicken
and music guitars and things like that
and not like a
martial arts ninja and karate and stuff
yeah that's what
what do you do for money now oh i got
some scooter okay instead of cheating
that's what i'm doing
i'm [ __ ] how much how much money do
you get a month hit this
about 15 000 here about about 12 but 200
months already
you know 15 000 a year about 14 000
dollars a year about 12 49 i worked out
of that team
yeah oh well yeah it's it sounds good
down so
this part of appalachia is is one of the
poorest parts of the country yeah it's
probably the point
there's ain't no jobs in here if you
want to get you get to go like two hours
about an hour and a half drive to london
or
way down jackson we're around here also
yours called main log and common brought
out like obama and hillary clinton
i'll start war on calling of cold
companies and uh common that'll be
today they shut us down they don't buy
foot cadillac convertible and you hate
stuff you gotta hate stuff
you uh uh uh collision that's what they
fight first i every time
yeah so coal mining is fading away and
yeah there's really no other options no
no company wants to
open up a factory here because it's so
remote yeah it sold them out yeah
but uh uh if we get a factory paper
job but most people they get they get
ground here and they just put water take
anybody around man
cause like right here they they all the
thirty and a half mile forty ninety bull
skin rather
and they wanted to happen next door and
hit nothing down through there i went to
the store right there
and he kind of thought they made the
gamers around here what they get over
there they ain't number gaming
animals nobody live in your neighborhood
yeah
you know so the medium income
of some of the counties here it was
higher in 1979 than it is today
yeah yeah yeah it seems like this way of
life is just fading away from yeah
they said you said you could start
working one call company and right now
that the
average pay i said my dad worked out he
was like you know at 90 right there he's
making
love somewhere right there and now the
normal pace uh like they search out like
20 21 dollars a hour there
and uh daddy said you stood there you
could be working one call coming right
there and quit year
and go down the next house dirt and next
car coming out harley union and fish
today up
yeah but now if you're in a job you take
a job at a restaurant or a
garage store or something like that
you're taking a blog
it's like 20 years you take a tree and
it takes about 20 25 years we'll get
better tolerance out there
what are your favorite things about
appalachia well the mounds and the
game and uh just climb it's a good place
to live there for you know if you find
about to make a labor day what are the
worst things about living here uh
what the uh the snow and winter is cold
right there but uh
maybe it's a wheelchair for the moment
there i mean you go anywhere that's like
a little thing with clayton right there
you go biggest hill around here just
digging into the ice like snowflakes
right there nicely chain
and when i started saying like they
moved the bottle so the first thing i
want to do is go over to
advance i think you said wheelchair
because some snow whatever don't you
hear every
one diameter so i got myself which i
passed four driving this one
you know i'm already trying to stay
around buy them or turn on my boss
and i worked there first get this my
son's uh
the sunset uh about turtle canyon's over
there they come by and test me don't
even tell me every place meeting
everything you know everything he
checked me out
he got to tell him stole me to go up
front said if anything caught stones
right there i said you'd buy some wrists
did you run away from
i run it i i got retired
have you had you traveled before uh i've
traveled i've been up north indiana ohio
and
that's uh uh uh the great smuggling
mountain tennessee dollywood down there
you know
been over north and west virginia and
first west it means that
uh uh somerset about 30 counties over
yeah yeah and i've been very far
i mean do you see that you know the
technology that's taking over the world
is
is kind of leaving appellation behind
yeah well
yeah if we go well you go
i about alone it's about about an hour
hour and a half drive
you know i send the fire there the hub
of uh ace new thunder their i-75
you know you go there and they they
search at the factory they're 15-20
dollars however
that that's been on fire i can't affect
it that's where by school london
and my cousin you know i'm a cousin they
that's what they do at longer than real
place right behind place that's really
close to work because you you drive an
hour and a half
and then drive back right there and then
you get get the house there and if you
don't get plenty of wrestling you feel
like hell forever retirement
so basically what doesn't strike me do
you find having
you know your accent is very thick the
appalachian accent is so thick that
when you go to places like ohio or
anything yeah yeah yeah
you can feel like a martin man i'll say
about them southern rock band up in
indiana right there they coming they
sound like a city [ __ ] something they
type right
choir and everything you're doing makes
it difficult for you to move to a bigger
city
yeah to to change your life right yeah
yeah so you're kind of stuck here
yeah hey mcgregor may retire hey six 66
the 17th of
uh uh uh september to him david the same
agent
and uh he was talking some factor of
indiana up there yeah
and you have friends here oh yeah i got
a few friends i got i'm kind of
quiet and shy i teach myself right there
yeah i got a few friends i got a friend
named jordan he started out there the
walmart they see that long enough
have you been in love before i was
married once yeah i
i might have gone unless you bought over
on uh oh river road and clay came there
and we stayed together about uh five
years and then when i just
and uh i ain't done that forever and i
thought uh that perception anybody would
see anything your brain doesn't see you
here thank you celebrating your brother
i'll
see you next year anything another guy
you know and when i cleared up there he
went realtor and i thought she looked up
about bugging me and i just left i
didn't go back there and she went
laughing and we just got divorced man
schizophrenia you got is under control
now yeah he
really excuse friends the doctor was
diagnosed first time he said
schizophrenia but one of his canvas
psychos was
you're fine now yeah i'm fine now yeah
he's cleared up so clarence uh
do you have children oh i got one boy
yeah constantly on caster he'll be 20
year olds 26 to violence
he's going to take out do you raise him
uh i raised the four
because he got forward when i went when
we broke up when i left when
he got the voters there and uh he said
with his mother and his uh
i was i was uh my father okay see alex
junior about them
how old are you oh i'm uh i came 44 to
15 like this month
15 hours you're 44 44. what's the most
important lesson you've learned in life
getting better early when the long
flight they feed the floor and uh
do your nine to five and get [ __ ]
because uh and it's not what state
you throw at drugs and alcohol man you
gotta work you know may not work you
start doing dietary man
yeah you gotta work all right you wanna
play a little music
yeah yeah but let me yeah all right
yeah i brought my own song return uh
this is uh
i got my same yeti return that i ain't
never put me used to i got about 12 over
there that i've got them complete return
so this might sing over here laid out
somewhere here like you know you first
saw it there
and i don't know if you like it or not
but i'll play one all right
all right miss called uh
cartoon usa yep all right
i need flex metal boys just in the
workshop this is a little damn though
okay all right
[Music]
hold on here hello jesus
hmm
[Music]
highway so come on down have a good time
hold it down for daddy's day first down
usa
awesome yeah i got one more you'll get
one more this is the best one this is
good it's about my granny caught the
concrete balls out right there yeah
graham's a whisker
you hear this it's gonna be hard to beat
that okay
i've looked at a little juice here so
this this client's cast is comfortable
however it's good in here